uh hello everyone I'm happy to see every
one of you and thank you for coming
I will speak about some challenges that
can arise in Bayesian modeling in
particular about empirical determinacy
and sensitivity
I'm sure most of you have heard a famous
expression by a well-known mathematician
Church box who said that all models are
wrong but some are useful
and he also said that since all models
are wrong the scientists must be alert
to what is importantly wrong
and the main goal of this project I am
going to present now is to honor the
scientists about the wrong models they
fit in patient analysis
I will start with some basic notation In
classical statistics we assume y1 and Y
and observations from the random
variable y with density function f
in order to estimate the fixed parameter
Theta we optimize the likelihood
function
however in the base and inference this
fixed data parameter is not fixed
anymore but it's assumed to be random
um
and we have to assume that this random
parameter follows to some distribution
in Bayesian inference it's called a
prior distribution
and what we do here we have to estimate
the part Theta parameter which is random
now so we have to estimate the
distribution of the Theta
given the prime the data Y which is
called the posterior distribution we are
doing so by using the base theorem which
says that the posterior is proportional
to the likelihood times the prior that
we assume
and I will continue with some motivation
the two main challenges that arising the
Basin modeling are the sensitivity and
the lack of empirical determinacy
the lack of empirical determinacy in the
sense that the parameters the posterior
cannot be learned from the data it it
can happen sometimes that the posterior
is not dependent is not affected
affected by the likelihood
it is important to know that when we
assume a prior or we have a data what
will happen with the posterior when we
perturb the prior or the data a little
bit
which is not known until now
about the non-identification and and
empirical non empirical determinacy In
classical statistics gustavson said that
the Gustafson defines the
non-identification as the violation of
the root and Rule which says that
the width of the confidence interval is
proportional to 1 over square root of n
this means that when we have more data
more we have larger sample we have a
narrower confidence interval if the
model is identified
and to and vice versa if we have a
smaller sample size we have wider
confidence interval but it can happen
that we have more data but the parameter
doesn't get the confidence interval of
the parameter doesn't get narrower
because it is not impacted by the data
so we want to find these problems in the
patient hierarchical models
it is it challenging Invasion modeling
because for example in the classical
statistics if you have such problems of
non-identification you get convergence
problems and you cannot estimate the
parameter Theta usually in the
applications however in the Basin
analysis because of the prior
assumptions you may get an estimation of
the Theta without knowing that it's not
impacted by the data but it only depends
on the assumed prior
so we will try to clarify this problem
and to find out how the data impacts the
spread or the location of the posterior
distribution
in for doing so we change the sample
size we assume we have more sample more
data or less and we will check what
happens with the posterior
there are several other other works in
the literature who are doing similar
work in particular I want to mention the
data cloning by Lele and others who take
the same data and clone it repeated two
three times and use the Clone data as as
like original data this is a good
approach but it doesn't work very well
for smaller sample sizes for example if
you have only two data points you clone
it you have you don't gain much
information
another work is the scaling
which is also done by myself and my
co-authors but this is also uh is this
in this project we also change the
sample size but in a different way where
we uh
scale a particular parameter in the base
and meta-analysis hierarchical normal
normal hierarchical model we scaled
within study standard deviation which
mimics change of the sample size
this approach also works but it's not
General it only applies to the
meta-analysis models
and for uh we we try to go for more
General approach which I'm going to
present now this is a paper a recent
version will be available in the patient
analysis journal in coming weeks but if
you need more details you can read the
archive version of this paper
there is also a package called ad for
BHM empirical dietary aminocy for
Bayesian hierarchical models which is
available on my GitHub page and it
allows you to apply this approach for
based on hierarchical models
and this is written in our node python
so how do we change the sample size here
for uh so that it can be applied for
more General problems and models we wait
the likelihood
for example in a latent calcium model
the posterior from the base parameter
one here means for the base parameter
where the waiting
the parameter is one the posterior
distribution for the base non-weighted
model is equal to the likelihood times
the latent field times the prior is
proportional
and what we do we just raise the
likelihood to the power of w
and try to calculate the weighted
posterior from this model already
this W is a value close to one it's like
one plus or minus Delta and it
it mimics up something or down sampling
for example when w is bigger than one it
means that we give more weight to the
likelihood and when w is smaller than
one it gives less weight to the
likelihood
so when we have the posterior from the
base model and the posterior from the
weighted model we want to see what
happened what what's the difference
between these two after waiting
and do it for doing so we choose the
patriarch coefficient
which is sorry
which is a metric that measures the
overlap between two distributions in our
case between the base and weighted
posterior distributions and it is
related to the proper distance between
distribution cylinder distance with this
relation
we assume that we have a exponential
family distributions in such models this
means that it is possible to approximate
this distributions with a normal
distribution
and for
normal distributions particular
coefficient between two normal
distributions is possible to get in a
closed form with corresponding
expectations and standard deviation
it has this form
and so the bachelorette coefficient
between the base and weighted posteriors
is approximated with the biatorial
coefficient between them their normal
approximations
so this is the main measure we Define
it's called we call it total empirical
determinacy
which is defined to be the negative
second derivative of the partial
coefficient with respect to the weighted
Factor w
the second derivative of such Divergence
measures is a common way to
to quantify the change after some
perturbations to change in distributions
and the minus sign is there to have
relation between the proper density H
squared helical distance
so we have some computational issues we
need to approximate the second
derivative of the pi trial coefficient
between the normal the posterior
distributions and we are using the
central difference uh
way to formula to approximate the second
order derivative
so we with this I will go back to the
Ted formula with this week can we can
understand what happens what what
changes the posterior distributions what
happens if we wait till I collude how
the posterior changes but what is more
interesting is to understand how the
location or spread parameter change in
the posterior distribution
so I can recall here The Bachelorette
coefficient between two normal
distributions which has this nice form
and we divide it between two parts we
call it BCL and BCS BCL is the partial
coefficient between the locations it's
it it is a common non-distance model
novice distance and the second product
is the BCS which is connected to the
uh
to the standard deviations so the BCL
will quantify the changing locations and
the PCL BCS will quantify the change in
standard deviations
similar to the Ted measure we Define edl
and EDS
completely in the same way like the
negative second derivative of paragraph
coefficient for the location and the
negative second derivative of departure
coefficient for the spread
and this nice formulas allows us to
derive a very useful formulation where
Ted the total empirical determinacy for
a parameter is equal to the empirical
determinacy for location plus the
empirical deterministry of spread and
this allows us to understand to
which proportion of the total change is
due to the change in location and which
proportion is due to the changing
in in spread
so for implementations I I will
introduce the software we have used we
have applied to
known techniques mcmc sampling and
approximate posterior by nested LaPlace
approximations for the mcmc sampling
there are two very known softwares the
first is Jacks developed by Professor
Martin Plummer who is a co-author of
this paper
and there is a package that allows us to
work with Jacks from the our environment
the second software is called stun which
is developed by Professor Andrew Gelman
and his team
and there is also a nice package
developed by again Martin Plummer which
allows us to to Diagnostic and
convergence checks of the mcmc samples
after the estimation
another way to approximate posterior is
a numerical method by Professor Rue who
is also co-author of this paper
so how we do the waiting how we handled
with the waiting in this uh
programs in England it's easy because
similar is very fast for such small
models it runs in seconds so it's not a
problem to run English several times
there is a nice argument in in-law call
which is called weights for the normal
base model the weights argument is equal
to one and
for getting awaited likelihood we just
need to change the value of the W to 1
minus Delta or one plus Delta and we
re-run the model two more times to in
order to estimate the central difference
of the partial coefficient the second
order derivative of particular
coefficient
uh in in mcmc based algorithms it is a
little challenging for Jacks for example
we don't want to run this model several
times because they took much longer for
drugs we have derived the formula where
the post weighted posterior is
proportional to the likelihood raised to
some power times the base samples of the
posterior
and the way the likelihood samples from
the first Jack skull can be derived from
the Tavian statistics which has this
expression
and so we get the samples of the
weighted posterior
and for Stan it's uh it's even more
challenging I would say because you
cannot extract the like cute samples
but it's easier to generate a quantity
the likelihood samples during the call
of the stun of the model
after having the weighted posterior
samples we need to approximate to
estimate the expectation and the
standard deviation for the weighted
posterior samples
with these formulas
and it is always good to equip the
Monte Carlo estimates with stand Mark of
with Monte Carlo standard errors for
doing so assume we have an mcmc sample
that explores our posterior of length m
and for each statistic of interest for
each quantity we have to we want to
compute we generate bootstrap samples
and we calculate the statistics of
interest and then the standard errors
for each statistic can be calculated
with this formula
I already talked about our package which
works with all of this
estimation techniques
and now I want to move to the
applications
the first I will focus on the
challenging data set where we have
complete separation in in the data what
is a complete separation
in a in a very simple case for a binary
data it occurs when one exploratory
variable predicts the outcome perfectly
in such a case for example in a two tube
table we will have zeros for this
observed frequencies and
it will cause a numerical problem when
estimating the parameters
for a logistic regression
so for this challenging data set we will
we know that we have identification and
data determinacy problem so we will
challenge our method to see if we can
capture this problem with our measure
so I will uh introduce three examples a
normal example and two page and logistic
regressions with
separation data
the first one is a simple example is
just to show how the model works
we assume we have a n equal to 10
observations of Y
and we have the sample mean variance and
the Precision
and we from from the simulation study
and we assume a very basic normal model
for the observations why with mu
expectation and precision Kappa and we
have to assume a prior Distribution on
on the expectation parameter M with some
hyper parameters for the prior
distribution
for such a simple model it is possible
to derive our measures and also
analytically and in this table I showed
the results from analytical calculations
inline checks and you can see that they
match perfectly
and
this is not very informative because we
have only one parameter in this simple
model but we already can see that the
proportion of changing the spread of the
posterior is one compared to the change
of the location which means that this
parameter is determined by the data is
well determined by the data so when so
when we wait this data this parameter
will be informed
the second
application I want to present is about
based on logistical questions on
on a data with complete complete
separation I think most of you are
most of you know the logistic regression
and this is only the patient case of it
where we assume priors on the intercept
and the slope parameters there is a
paper that recommends this specific
prior Suite prior parameters for
um for analysis of data with separation
so the first data set with complete
separation is from bacterial resistance
data they have they had some strains of
Assyria Collide bacteria isolates we got
this data set from the medical
microbiology Institute from the
University of Zurich
where they have two different types of
bacteria
resistant and susceptible resistance
means that if you put an antibiotic on
this bacteria this the bacteria will not
be dead
and susceptible means that the bacteria
will die with the given antibiotic
so after an antimicrobial susceptibility
testing which is the following I will
try to describe it shortly so they have
some discs and they brush the bacteria
on it and they put an antibiotic in the
middle of it and they they put these
plates in an incubation phase after I
think like eight hours they measure the
diameter of around the antibiotic the
diameter of all the bacteria that are
dead because of the antibiotic it can be
different because the and the bacteria
are different they they might not die or
they might that with that and this
diameter is called inhibitions on
diameter which has values between 6 and
40 millimeters six is because of the
diameter of the antibiotic in the middle
so they cannot
estimate they cannot measure the values
that are smaller than six
and we have three different
experiments one with three with three
different antibiotics one with imapenum
Amoxicillin and subtraction
so you can see that we have three
different
positions of the data where the black
Parts show the
resistant bacteria and the gray ones are
the susceptible
you can see that we have an overlap of
resistant and susceptible bacteria we
have classic separation and we have
complete separation
so we have applied our methodology on
all these three types and to see whether
we get problems in in the separate
shrink case
I have a table here with some results
the numbers are maybe a bit smaller but
I will try to describe all these values
are here in order to just see that they
are they agree between the
methods and parameters what is important
here is the total empirical determinacy
of all the intercept and slope
parameters for all three data sets we
can see that
again the empirical determinacy measure
also agrees between the
methods
and
what is even more interesting is the
proportions of the change in location
and spread of the posterior distribution
I will recall that for the first data
set we had overlap and we have the Peds
the change in spread equal to 1 which
means that these parameters Alpha and
beta are determined by the data
for the amoxicillin we have
quasi-complete separation and we already
see that the
change in in the posterior is not only
due to the change in spread but also due
to the change in location
and for the subtraction where we have
complete separation we already see that
the spread doesn't change much when we
wait the likelihood
this means that we these parameters in
this model for this data set are not
well determined by this data
we did a simple experiment I will go
back to this data pictures again we took
the first data set with email PanAm we
have where we have two overlaps of the
resistant and susceptible bacteria and
we shifted the resistant once the black
bars to the left one by one in order to
simulate different separation uh
rating the data set so you got 20
different data sets with 20 different
stages of the separation
and we applied the techniques to all
these 20 data sets in this first figure
we plot the M total empirical
determinacy and on the last one we plot
the proportional empirical determinacy
of location and spread for both data
sets and both
methods
I will focus on the second plot here
this is more interesting so we can see
that the
proportion of the location is close to
zero when the separation is small and it
costs up to one when the separation rate
increases and similarly for the for the
spread proportion of the change in the
spread is it starts with one and goes
down close to zero as the separation
rate increases
and this is another application of
Hemophilia aging this is a disease
in this data set we can we we have 52
observations
22 of them are carriers of Hemophilia
and 30 are non-carriers this is a
similar application only that here we
have two covariates X1 and X2 and we
apply this model to the data set and you
can see the separation line so we again
have a separation problem
and uh
the empirical determinacy measures are
shown here again for the Ted
the main the values it's interesting
that for the intercept the TD values is
smaller and it is larger for the slope
parameters and this Behavior remains for
all three method methods
and most importantly the proportional
measures of changing location and
changing spread we can see that the
proportion of change in spread is much
larger than the one in in location
and this is also an alert that there
might be a problem and we know the
problem is the complete separation
so there are some limitations of this
methodology
and further Works where we want to
choose the Delta for weighting the
likelihood in a more clever way probably
uh we could modify the method to cope
with integer rates for example and this
will be comparable with the cloning
method I showed at the beginning
and at the moment our method is based on
the mean and standard deviation on the
descriptive statistics for the location
spread but it would be good to have a
measure that is for example based on the
context to have more stable results
and some strength of this method
for mcmc techniques a fast we have
developed a fast computation method in
order to not run the Jacks several times
the estimates of the empirical
determinacy are equipped with the
standard errors and what is what is the
most important is that the refined
method where we look at the proportions
uh proportions of change of the total
impact of the likelihood it allows us to
understand how the location or how the
spread is changing and this method is
already applicable to more General
outcomes not only normal or binary
and these are some references we
required in in the manuscript
and thank you very much for being here
and I'm happy to take some questions and
remarks
[Applause]
thank you for the great presentation uh
one question related to the choice of
the prior in your study so it seems you
use only normal normal
uh yes what if you change the priors and
how the result can change did you have
some exercise from that
uh
because we have chosen I will go to the
models first
sorry
yes for example here as I said we have
chosen priors that is recommended by
questioned others that is specific for
such a data set where we have separation
but for this application we didn't try
our other
priors because we have similar
applications in another paper where we
as we where we quantify the sensitivity
of the change in Prior so
but with other applications not on this
data set so here I don't know what will
happen we just have used the recommended
priors the goal was to understand the
impact of the perturbations of the
likelihood here but that's a valid
question it's interesting
thank you
I have a one or two part question
depending on the first part so
um is it ever the case that the scale
parameter of your posterior I guess
which is you're what you're trying to
determine would be
larger than the prior
that is
can you not simply determine
um or measure determinacy as how much
the posterior scale is smaller than the
prior scale
you mean the posterior by posterior
scale you mean the probability what we
compute it or it's something so the
change in the posterior already
uh you you mean the waiting part about
the scale perimeter of the posterior
distribution
can you repeat the question so so
is it ever the case that the posterior
variance of your perimeter is smaller
than the prior variance or I'm sorry is
larger than the prior variance I guess
I'm just wondering can you merely
measure
determinancy as whether
the posterior
variance is smaller than the prior
variance oh I got the question but um
I don't know how much the prior variance
has to do with the changing the
likelihood
because when we want to understand if
the parameter is stated that their mind
we are working with the posterior but
the change in the prior is already the
sensitivity part right and
I guess I'm wondering if without any
data if you set the weight on the data
to zero the likelihood zero then the
posterior would be exactly the prior
yeah
if you set the weight to one
then the posterior will hopefully be
different from the prior
I would I would think that it would only
be smaller and
it's a difficult question I don't know
we didn't think about the first the
prior scale in this uh okay method
different question
um this reminds me a little bit about of
the the bootstrap or the the jackknife
and the the bootstrap for example
instead of scaling the likelihood it
randomly scales the likelihood and I
would think that if the posterior
happens to completely or if if the
distribution
um
completely matches the prior then it
might appear that that there's no
determinacy but if if instead of that
weight Vector you're choosing a single
wave Vector but if you randomized it a
little bit you might
get better Precision have you thought
about them that's a good question yes
we talked to know yes randomization
would be a good extension we tried to
change the weight to have integers or
or
to to have some clever way to choose it
but also yes certain randomization would
be also we didn't work with it but we
had this idea from a reviewer whether
this can be considered as a random
parameter in the model we didn't work on
it yet it's a good extension and it
would be interesting to know
thank you for the questions
[Applause]